hey 42 here have extraterrestrials
visited our planet these terrifying
real-life abduction stories seem to
suggest that not only have they visited
they've been here for a while watching
girls experimenting on us and even
crossbreeding with humans
one eerie night in 1976 in rural Maine
for friends who had met at art school
went on a camping trip on the second
night they noticed a very bright light
in the sky and then on the third night
undeterred by the looming threat of
alien abduction they decided to go for a
spot of night fishing whilst fishing out
on the canoe they noticed the same
bright light again one of the men used
his flashlight to make an SOS pattern at
the mysterious light now this wouldn't
prove to be one of his wisest decisions
ever because shortly afterwards the
ominous light rapidly expanded and
engulfed all four of them like an alien
pac-man on steroids
the next thing the men remembered was
waking up back at their campsite with
absolutely no idea how they got there
and what had happened in between the
fire they had stoked up before they left
was now completely burned out and all
that was left was a pile of ash now if
that doesn't scream we'd been abducted
by aliens and inexplicably lost a
substantial period of time then I don't
know what does but no the four men
fought nothing more of it and finished
their camping trip acting like
everything was just fine but in the
weeks are followed strange things
started to happen firstly all four men
started to have the same horrific
nightmares about being aboard a
spaceship with mysterious beings that
had long necks and large heads in each
of the nightmares one of the men was
being humiliatingly experimented on
whilst he over free men helplessly
watched unable to intervene it was at
this point they realized something
serious went down during that camping
trip so disturbed by their dreams the
men later met with a group of UFO
specialists who suggested that they
undergo regressive hypnosis therapy to
make all the horrific
memories come flooding back during the
sessions all four men revealed
remarkably similar memories of being
abducted and experimented on being
artists all four men were able to
accurately sketch their abductors as
well as the spacecraft all of the men
sketches were freakishly similar
following psychiatric examinations the
men were all deemed to be mentally
stable and they all passed lie-detector
tests the unnerving event has since come
to be known as the allagash abductions
and at the time it reached national
primetime news next up is the horrific
story of the abductions of Jesse Leung
Jesse long is a man from Tennessee who
claims he was first abducted by aliens
in 1957 when he was just five years old
Jesse and his brother were playing on
the hill behind his house when they came
upon what appeared to be a round house
under construction the two boys
obviously hadn't seen enough sci-fi
horror movies because instead of fleeing
they stayed to examine the UFO like
object closer then according to Jesse a
tall man appeared next to him and
flashed him with a bright light Jesse
was instantly paralyzed from head to toe
Jesse didn't remember anything more
about the event until years later when
Jesse underwent some hypnosis sessions
during the sessions Jesse remembered
himself and his brother being led down a
long hallway then separated jesse was
placed on a flat table and he recalled
an object being implanted into his left
shin the object remained inside Jesse's
leg for 34 years until in 1991 he had an
operation to remove it from his leg alas
Jesse skeptics could deny his
convictions no more because sure enough
there was a strange small object inside
his left shin the object appeared to be
a shard of glass however it was sent for
further research at a laboratory and the
research came up with some extremely
bizarre results the Southwest Research
Institute who examined the supposed
alien object had this to say the object
had a very remarkable composition and it
exhibited unique
surface characteristics that cannot be
explained and that the questions
outnumbered the answers
Jessie claimed he has been abducted
again multiple times over the years and
in one particular apparently extremely
traumatic abduction Jessie was forced to
crossbreed with what he believed was a
female alien being in 1990 Jessie lung
was driving to New Orleans right outside
of Albuquerque New Mexico when a light
appeared and Jessie's car was lifted off
the interstate and he was brought up
inside an alien craft with Jessie still
inside his car Jessie was then placed on
a table and presented with an alien baby
and told this is your child
Jessie wasn't sure whether they were
simply informing him of his new alien
child or they were seeking child
maintenance
either way they seemed rather proud of
what they had accomplished now this next
case is very rare because it's one of
the few alien abduction cases that
doesn't end in mutilation death or weird
alien babies it actually has a happy
ending John Salter jr. was traveling on
the highway with his son when suddenly
they discovered they were driving in the
wrong direction and they had lost an
hour of time now we all know what
happens next the two men had no memory
of what had happened during their lost
hour and continued with their journey as
normal however a little while later they
apparently saw a UFO in the sky seeing
the mysterious alien craft in the air
jogged John and his sons memories and
they started to remember the strange on
disturbing events that took place during
their hour of lost time
the two men were called seeing a group
of children under taller half-human
half-alien creature however the men both
said they were not afraid of the aliens
they instead felt extremely protected
and they felt a strong connection with
the alien beings
the two men were then guided into a room
by their new alien bodies where they
underwent a for medical examination and
peculiar procedure
however unlike over alien abduction
victims John and his son reported an
overall improvement in their health but
by far the weirdest part of the story
and the thing that makes it the most
believable is that John had a scar on
his forehead however after his abduction
the scar had completely vanished in most
alien abduction cases the abductee is
somewhat safely returned to Earth and
then they tell others of their abduction
but this adds a level of uncertainty
into the validity of that story because
they could of course be making it all up
that's what makes his next case so
believable because unlike in most
abduction stories Frederick Valentich
was never ever seen again
twenty-year-old Frederick Valentich was
an aspiring pilot in Australia until on
the 21st of October 1978 during a
training flight of the southeast coast
of Australia something completely
unexplainable happened during his flight
Valentich radioed Melbourne's air
traffic control to advise them that he
was being shadowed by an unidentified
craft flying about a thousand feet above
him frederick said the craft was
circling his own and it was emitting an
eerie green light he then told air
traffic control that he was experiencing
engine problems air traffic control
asked him to describe the other aircraft
to which Frederick replied it's not an
aircraft and then suddenly the
transmission was interrupted by metallic
scraping sounds and all contact was lost
a four day long search was undertaken of
an area 1,000 square miles large but no
trace of Frederick Valentich or his
aircraft was ever found when the police
questioned nearby witnesses there were
numerous reports of people citing the
UFO in the sky above Australia on the
night of Frederick's disappearance and
finally is the spookily convincing
abduction of Travis Walton
Travis is an American lager who on the
5th of November 9
1875 at 22 years old was working with a
logging crew in the apache-sitgreaves
National Park in Arizona when Travis and
his crew finished for the day
they were driving home in the same truck
when all the men spotted a bright
yellowish light from behind a hill up
ahead
they drove closer and they saw the large
golden disc hovering above a clearing
the driver stopped the truck and Walton
leaped out and ran towards the disc the
others shouted at Wilson to stop and
come back to the truck but he carried on
regardless the rest of the crew insist
that they saw a Bluegreen light come
from the disc and strike Walton Walton
then rose a foot into the air with his
arms and legs outstretched and then he
disappeared along with the hovering gold
disc the other men reported the incident
to the police deputy sheriff when they
got home the sheriff reported that all
the men were distraught and two of them
were in tears a large search party then
carried out a search for Walton over the
next few days but there was no trace of
it until five days later when Travis
Walton mysteriously reappeared
disturbingly Walton had lost a
significant amount of weight during his
five days of lost time
his story reached national news and he
has since wrote a book detailing his
apparent encounter with a UFO thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2